according to one 2018 study around half
of british men in their 30s report
difficulties getting or maintaining an
erection this is only going to get worse
i think with gen z because the most
socially anxious generation that we've
ever had highest rates of introversion
social anxiety disorders and stuff like
that getting naked with somebody you
know that's gonna push a lot of people's
buttons
zac talander welcome to the show
i'm here
we're both here again
and uh every time i'm on your show i'm
closer to you
so
for the people who aren't aware we live
together and you are sat on the other
side of that home
because i don't have an in-person
recording set up so we're doing it this
way which is
virtually but also kind of in person and
we can kind of hear each other through
the doors yeah that's the most
concerning part is i can hear you
through the door
headphones but but it's all good double
it's all good baby double chris how are
you doing you good
i'm good man i'm good had a good week so
far good content
uh i don't know man so much has happened
since i was last on the show but it's
hard to know exactly what has happened
because
you and i live together so i'm talking
about it all the time yeah i can't
really update you
but uh yeah still doing the same thing
you're doing the same thing even better
better and brighter bigger bigger guests
and also being on joe rogan too that was
wild wild experience yeah man
absolutely wild uh
it's been strange i mean it's the number
one podcast in america canada australia
new zealand and england or the uk at the
moment it's the number one podcast
episode
in all of those places which is
it's just a terrifying way
yeah
wow
that's because i shared it you think
yeah yeah i got you the most shared tag
on spotify good i'm glad you're welcome
uh other things that have been happening
in countries outside of ours
wnba star brittany greiner sentenced to
nine years in russian prison
so i i saw that i didn't really dive
deep into that
um but does that mean that she still
can't get extradited or traded for so
this is the most recent update this is
from daley wire wnba star brittany
greiner was sentenced to nine years in a
russian prison on thursday russian
prosecutors had argued that greiner who
was convicted of sneaking marijuana
vaping materials into the country should
serve nine and a half years in prison so
she saved half a year i guess the
request came during closing arguments in
a court outside moscow nearly six months
after the six foot nine inch wnba star
was nabbed an airport with contraband
the us has been trying to negotiate her
release reportedly considering offering
a notorious russian arms dealer
imprisoned here as a trade so i'm not
sure if
that guy is maybe gonna
be
swapped out for her or something but
it's a difficult situation do you want
to let a notorious russian arms dealer
go no
do you want a wnba star that had a vape
cartridge on her get jailed for nine
years in a russian ghoul like also no
kind of
kind of hard to
thread the needle i never meant to hurt
anybody and i never meant to put in
jeopardy the russian population i never
meant to break any laws here griner said
prior to the delivery of the verdict in
kim ki city courthouse i made an honest
mistake and i hope that you're ruling
that in your ruling it doesn't end my
life here i know everybody keeps talking
about political porn and politics but i
hope that is far from this courtroom uh
blah blah blah she said that she only
brought them to russia by mistake only
used kind of this is it grineer who
plays for the wnba's phoenix mercury had
flown to russia to finish a season for
ummc
ekka turinberg when she was arrested
team compete so she was over there
playing dude can you imagine
accidentally having or even on purpose
thinking i can fly a vape cartridge in
and then getting
nine years in russia she's been there
for six months already she's already
detained
nine years in prison
yeah so uh i think
a lot of the wnba stars the best of the
wmea they go
to other countries to make more money uh
i think they they pay
athletes for uh for women's basketball
and particularly a lot more so
a lot of women do this this is a very
common practice but this is also not
just russia that has rules like this a
lot of middle eastern countries doesn't
bali have like uh crazy drug rules as
well like thailand is death if you're
caught with the wrong drug i think they
still have the death sentence for people
that are caught with the wrong drug
james was telling me about
some guy who had some marijuana and i
think it was in singapore
and or i'm not entirely sure what
country it was
i know it was southeast asia and
he had uh whipping like they had to they
whipped him
no or like [ __ ]
a certain amount of lashes yes
what is this are we on a pirate ship
is this the 1700s what's going on dude
and then um he he was telling me another
story about how well he had a bunch of
stories about this uh because he's
covered it a lot but there was a guy
who
he was a a
football coach so soccer coach and he um
he was taking his buddy to the airport
okay uh in i think it was dubai or
something and his buddy messaged him on
whatsapp saying
hey by the way i have a cbd pen that i
left in your car
and the authorities
uh were able to hack that message and
arrested him
like they they stopped his car took him
out of there found the cbd or whatever
and i think he's rotting in jail was
that
i i think this one is a middle eastern
country right okay but again i'm not
entirely sure what the he said it was
like a football coach or something like
dubai and the united
emirates is somewhere you do not want to
get caught with drugs so i remember
reading this story a few years ago about
a guy that had a trace amount of
marijuana on the bottom of his shoe
on the bottom of his shoe so he'd stood
in maybe some marijuana maybe it was his
maybe it wasn't he was jailed for that
i've got another
news story here which is from april 2021
american facing years into by prison
after cannabis traces found in urine a
man who legally enjoyed some cannabis in
his home of las vegas is now facing
three years in prison in the united arab
emirates after being caught with traces
of it in his urine peter clark fleet
dubai on february 24th on a business
trip looking for a recording studio the
retired game designer then went to
hospital following a pancreatitis attack
he was reported to authorities when
doctors found hashish traces in his
urine which is considered possession in
the uae
oh
my god
[Laughter]
oh my god
that is insane that's that is insane
that's crazy dude medic medic
they were probably
forced to do that right it wasn't like
like it's part of their job i'm sure i
think they'll probably like they would
get obliged they would be obliged if
they see it to report it yes yes i don't
think they're probably going out of
their way but they'll have said what is
it that i'm going to do blah blah blah
we've found some weed we need to we need
to report this to the authorities
and if we don't we'll get in trouble oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure uh but yeah
that's that brittany greiner thing is i
mean rogan posted about it earlier on
today saying that
uh there's people that are still in jail
now in the u.s for drugs
in states
for drugs that are now legal in those
states
that's wild and what's the what is i
can't believe i can't think of it um
after a law is
like once the law has changed you can't
get charged for it or something like
that it was
uh i can't think of the the term but if
they
change the law
after you've broken it you can't go to
jail for it and i think vice versa
works as well oh and i don't know what
that what the term is but well there's
that that's that thing it's double
jeopardy or whatever it is where you
can't be trying slice yeah yeah so
that's that's definitely but dude i mean
it just
i feel
so bad for this britney grinder girl
like can you imagine being a an athlete
peak of your sport
randomly got something in your suitcase
nine years in a russian prison i wonder
if it plays out like what are the odds
that
she
is
never traded for to come back to the
united states and has to play out and
live out these nine years what if she
like learns russian
has to join a gang you know to survive
and [ __ ]
that'd be so cool
and then like once she's let go she's
like
like
kind of never the same and like wants to
stay in russia you know russian double
agent with her like new family she gets
like a new lease on life
well i'm glad that you're being very
hopeful about this i wonder whether she
feels the same but uh yeah dude you got
to lean into it at that point
[ __ ] wild that's one of the things
you know for all the there's problems
with the west and stuff look at some of
the drug laws in different countries
look at some of the drug laws in the
middle east in the far east in russia
but
nine years for a vape cartridge i'd just
yeah it's very very very strange but
yeah i guess we'll wait and see and also
the other thing is let's say that
the best possible outcome here
is that the us loses a arms dealer
we get an arms dealer back out into the
world yeah that's the best possible
scenario and then we get a wnba starbuck
well also something else i wanted to
talk to you about is uh why young men
are turning to viagra i was really
struggling to get it up more men in
their 20s and 30s are taking little blue
pills for a variety of sexual ills from
erectile dysfunction to anxiety about
their performance in the bedroom ben
bryant speaks to users doctors and
relationship counselors about a very
curious phenomenon this is on the
independent and we spoke about this last
time one of the previous episodes that
you've been on we were talking about
um girls have an anxiety around not
being able to orgasm during sex and like
performance anxiety during
guys equivalent of that is
not getting it up
and
yeah and also how many commercials do we
have now where you can just get viagra
sent to you
right you you you uh kind of do you i
don't know if anyone's done these before
um i've had sponsorships like keeps
where you get it put in touch with the
doctor
the doctor fills out a prescription and
you get it sent to your house
and and that can happen in like within a
half hour well remember that you can get
over-the-counter viagra you don't need
to have the consultation with the doctor
and this is actually one of the things
that comes out of this really this news
story yeah you can just buy them over
there i mean blue chew right blue chew
is viagra chewing gum i think they
actually asked to sponsor the podcast
and i was they're not quite right i
don't think uh but
he was saying um after a breakup from a
five-year relationship james was nervous
about dating again he was 27 healthy and
had a good sex life but when it came to
sleeping with new people he was
experiencing performance anxiety i was
really struggling to get it up i get to
this point where i was having sex with
lots of people with like a 75 percent
error rate james assumed the problem was
just nerves he didn't seek advice from
his gp instead he started
self-medicating with sildenafil
better known as viagra it worked
instantly
when you take it you can actually focus
on enjoying sex and being in the moment
as opposed to going oh my god my dick is
failing no no don't stop keep going this
is
like that's that is exactly what your
mind says exactly for the girls that are
listening the fear that you have as a
guy as you
notice that that's
slowly creeping in is just this downward
spiral of and as you focus on it that is
exactly the first thing that's going to
cause it to go away
yeah i mean uh i'm not gonna lie
christopher it has happened to me for
sure
uh
i have
uh i have been in that situation usually
when i'm been drinking a little bit
and sometimes
you know in the past i have said this is
just not gonna happen and it's actually
much more of a relief than to just say
that
just it's not tonight
not tonight not tonight darling i'm
afraid yeah well i mean it's very
difficult for girls to not feel like
they've done something wrong it's like
that that whole scenario is just a it's
just a litany of embarrassment and men
feeling pretty ashamed of themselves
right like it's the one thing that
you're supposed to always be able to do
there's an expectation i think by
society that men should be hot to trot
all the time that they should always be
ready for sex and wanting sex and you
know this same is not expected of women
now there's other things that are
expected of women which you know like to
be able to orgasm during sex and to be
casual and all this sort of stuff but
it's pretty uncomfortable there was a
period while i was in uni and if looking
back now is so obvious
i'd had too much to drink i hadn't been
able to get it up when i was drunk then
i had a fear that that was going to
creep in when i was sober and over time
it did
so i'd managed to think myself into
performance anxiety physiologically
absolutely fine training in the gym
gaining loads of weight health
relatively healthy as healthy as a 21
year old club promoter can be um
and what i did how i fixed it was i
started to uh taper down a dose of
viagra during normal sex
so i would start with a half and then
less and then less and then less and
over time you realize i'm like licking
the outer coating of this this is
evidently not doing anything and you go
i'm kind of back but it was all about
performance anxiety and it's it's brutal
man
my theory a lot of it has to do with
masturbation and the prevalence of it in
young men i think
like it's something that definitely
cannot be ignored
right like
you find a way to self-stimulate i think
huberman talked about this on your
podcast you recently made a post about
it
uh and and i think that that's got to be
undeniable right like the the getting
used to
watching other people for arousal being
in the comfort of your own home you know
having your setup
you know
your playlists and your suggested videos
getting the getting the right video you
know all of that
that factors into somebody being like
well you know i might not have that when
i'm with a girl there's different
situations that can happen i'm not used
to this person what i have found is
whatever that anxiety is it dissipates
the more comfortable you get with that
woman i would agree more and more right
and i think
chris it would be hard to do your
technique of less and less of a dose
with a new woman each time
because i'm not sure if that's what you
were i'm not sure if that's what you
were doing but i feel like that would be
harder to do uh when when you have a new
woman new stimulus every single time and
the new pressure comes in if you're with
someone and you've been with them before
i think it's only natural that that sort
of
that that sort of anxiety goes away and
that's the beauty of actually having a
long-term relationship i agree right
that is one of the most underrated
aspects of it is that the romantic side
of things will undoubtedly get better
and if it doesn't then i think that's uh
you know a big point of error in your
relationship and and it might say
something else about the relationship i
always thought for a long time that
people that said you know sex in a
relationship is always going to be
better than one night stands just as
like a young
stupid guy
always thought that was like just
not accurate wisdom and i've come to
believe that it's the complete opposite
that guys often need to settle into who
they're having sex with the girls need
to learn what it is that they like to do
and you become more comfortable with
each other and the intimacy and all of
that actually ends up enhancing the way
that you have sex looking at some of the
stats from that article it says more
than 60
of uk viagra users are between 25 and 54
years old so one of the things that you
would think is well
younger people should have better
testosterone levels which should mean
that their sex drives higher but i guess
the other thing is that people over the
age of 54 years old are not having as
much sex so you have two parameters
going on right like one group of people
is physiologically more predisposed to
being able to get it up
but needs to get it up more the other
group is less so but also needs sex less
or is having sex less so i think there's
that little balance there it says
according to one 2018 study around half
of british men in their 30s report
difficulties getting or maintaining an
erection and this is only going to get
worse i think with gen z because the
most socially anxious
generation that we've ever had highest
rates of like introversion social
anxiety disorders and stuff like that
getting naked with somebody
is you know that's gonna push a lot of
people's buttons if they're
uncomfortable going out of the house or
going into nightclubs or loud noises
and clapping
getting naked with somebody's gonna be a
little bit too far
i think that the the testosterone
and the biological factors are the least
important when it comes to getting it up
for sure you know in both our cases
uh it had nothing to do with that it was
purely anxiety it was purely in the head
yep so so i think
i don't know i think that the
availability of viagra for sure has gone
up a hundred percent like it
the the fact that i could right now over
the course of this podcast order viagra
in in a half hour and have it delivered
to my door within days
that was just something that never
occurred
and now
now it's out and it's like well you
might as well if you're gonna get some
drinks on it takes away the anxiety
we don't really know the the negative
side effects i mean they they list them
but a long time of using
viagra over time like we don't know
exactly what that is but uh
it's definitely an option that men have
now there's a bit here the possible side
effects include a reduction in efficacy
over time as well as more serious
outcomes long-term use of viagra can
potentially increase the risk of
physiological dependency and has also
been associated with various problems
affecting the bearing the hearing and
visual
visual systems and division so
i mean
it's a but it's like it's like any drug
though if you
any drug it's
suggested to taper off of it and to come
back into it and you know it's the same
thing with caffeine the efficacy of
caffeine what what the side effects of
that are
um you went off of caffeine for how many
days 500 days yeah 500 days off of
caffeine right and
um a lot of people can cycle these drugs
that they just don't and that that's
another thing too i mean i think that
the caffeine industry is like one of the
craziest industries around caffeine and
nicotine industries you know people are
slinging a psychoactive drug that is
proven to be very effective but they're
not doing it really in a responsible way
i think if you look at what some of
these people order i mean i i know women
who are like
115 pounds
getting
300 milligrams of caffeine in their
starbucks
you know like a a very what's the large
one the venti yeah a venti cold brew
right that's gotta have around 300
milligrams of caffeine
and to do that and have that be part of
your morning like thing it's pretty
freaking intense
wouldn't you say rather than like one
little eight ounce cup you know one
little eight ounce cup of coffee to
start your day and then maybe another
one later on now people have like
monster
you know glasses of caffeine filled with
caffeine yeah i mean there's a whole
mosi quote where he talks about how if
you need to use a substance as a
if you can't function without them
they've stopped conferring a benefit be
able to stop them and only use them when
you really know you can crush on off on
off is typically good enough for most
but if you can't function without them
they've stopped conferring a benefit is
so on the money that's exactly how i
felt with caffeine it's like look this
isn't a performance enhancer it's a
crutch it's the only thing that's
actually keeping me going here but
another element to i guess add into the
viagra conversation is what it means or
how girls interpret it so this guy
mentioned that he wasn't telling his
partner wendy 37 says that she would be
unhappy to discover that her boyfriend
was secretly taking viagra because i
would feel like oh am i not good enough
uh but then i get more but then i get
the erectile dysfunction is more common
as guys get older so it's kind of brutal
it's like it's not about you it is not a
you thing it is almost exclusively
inside of my head and yet women are
all that they're going to be able to see
is
all of the self-image concerns and the
anxiety and the performance anxiety and
i'm not good enough
it's like a
really really bad situation
yeah and it's difficult i was just kind
of
having a retort to what you were saying
in my head and then i just flipped it a
little bit but it is a difficult
conversation or at least a difficult
position to say no it really isn't you
like it and i don't know how to prove
that to you but it's really not you it's
just overall anxiety
it's hard because you don't face this
anxiety but again the only thing you can
hope for is communication with your
partner like just open communication
like look this is what i've dealt with
this is you know whatever as long as you
are having sex and you're trying to get
better and you're pleasing your partner
and your partner's pleasing you there
are no real issues right there are
things that you can work on together as
long as you're open about whatever that
thing is i think but it is still a
difficult
you know hill to get on top to get to
get over
to uh to then try and convince them or
try to explain to them what this anxiety
really is yeah and i don't think
it's not comparable to women and orgasms
because they don't have to necessarily
explain why
they didn't have an orgasm they could it
might improve their sex lives but it's
not the same thing right because they
can still be obvious right right women
can either fake it or guys just don't i
mean there are guys that will ask like
did you come after you finished having
sex
but and i guess that that's probably a
pretty awkward especially if you're a
girl that maybe has performance anxiety
in bed that would probably suck to hear
but it's
i mean at least you've been able to have
sex i would say yeah
being pushed about orgasming during sex
is uncomfortable but it it doesn't get
into the same league really as not being
able to get it up speaking
about uh hot
like weird sort of sex things
tick tock star addison ray deletes
blasphemous holy trinity bikini photo
after backlash did you see this yep
sorry okay so tic toc star addison ray
on tuesday was hit with backlash for
posting a blasphemous bikini that was
holy trinity themed the father on her
right breast sun on her left breast and
holy spirit on her bottom ray reportedly
wore an adidas collaboration swimsuit
praying's holy trinity bikini and white
price a hundred dollars uh instagram
post showing off the bikini has been
since deleted uh
this is disrespectful to jesus sad what
you all are doing for money one comment
reportedly said another user adding so
messed up this is not okay blasphemy
someone wrote is nobody going to talk
about this disrespecting religions
another user reacted um
bikini blunder it's been called and
would she do it with islam or buddhism
as conservative beauty guru amanda
ensing
former white house photographer andrea
hanks commented any other faith and this
would be an issue tacky one thing that's
interesting is this is an issue
this isn't something where the christian
community has just rolled over and let
this sort of stuff happen so saying
uh any other faith and this would be an
issue kind of is a bit dumb because it
is an issue right and it isn't any other
faith
yeah um also just to interject here the
sun should be over where
the you know what i mean because it goes
father-son down here
and she had father and son on the left
and right breast the sun should have
been on the bikini bottom and holy
spirit up top yeah but that would be
weird though right to have a son
very weird it's very very very weird
what's she famous for what's addison
very famous for tick tick tock so she
does dances and she's she's good looking
she was in a movie right yeah and i
heard it was horrible i heard it was
horrible it was like a remake of 30 on
uh rotten tomatoes right yeah but you
know they made a ton of money on it just
for the fact that she was in it how many
gen z kids watched it just to be like oh
my god that's addison ray you know
um
but
what's the company called that that did
it that made the uh
oh no no but i thought i thought that
they had done it
wasn't there another company that called
like prayer or something
uh
i'm not sure i just i just saw a philip
defranco video on it
and like if you if you look at their
instagram they have a lot of um stuff
exactly like this i forget what it's
called i just watched this but yeah i
think this company i don't know if it
was
adidas um but
it should be adidas right because it's
adi dazzler
oh yes well you're the one that's
ruining it but yeah i mean
it's definitely it definitely seems like
um
the world hasn't allowed this one to
slide under the
under the radar so to speak i think if
it had been i wonder if it had been a
plus size model
if there would have been the equivalent
amount of backlash because there would
have definitely been accusations of
sizeism and fatphobia and slay queen and
stuff like that there's definitely upper
bounds on that
uh also
yeah i mean this is this is definitely
typical outrage but
i gotta tell you if it was this company
that i'm thinking of and not adidas i
don't know what adidas's affiliation
with it maybe
i don't know
but
i mean i didn't really know much about
addison ray i do now
you know and it's the same thing with
with any of this sort of backlash it's
it is brilliant marketing but it's also
i don't know if that's a legitimate way
to go about marketing i think this whole
you know brand their whole thing is to
try and create
something like this and this was their
golden ticket
their sales are going to go up
undoubtedly
yeah they have to uh well speaking of
people that have been using headlines to
pump current albums and stuff like that
demi lovato has changed her pronoun oh
she's added pronouns back in did you see
this
yes i did and i didn't know that it had
that an album was coming out as well
she's got an album coming out later this
month and didn't really make many
headlines it doesn't see but she uh she
updated her pronouns another day another
tiring pronoun debate pronouns are
simple they have been for centuries and
yet people are acting like their brand
new concept this is from the daily beast
it's very pro
uh demi this time the hot button topic
is being discussed not because of some
horrible remarks from bigoted
politicians or a terrible tweet from a
certain she who will not be named turf
but because singer and performer demi
lovato announced that she she is using
sorry
this is so hard to read performer and
demi lovato announced they are using
she her pronouns now in addition to the
they them pronouns they already utilize
lovato opened up about this in a recent
development in a gender identity journey
in an interview with the spout podcast
recently i've been feeling more feminine
so i have adopted she her again said
lovato i'm such a fluid person lovato
came out as non-binary in may 2021 blah
blah blah and then she reflected on
coming out and said that she's now
expanded
this is impossible to read lovato
reflected on this coming out journey and
also explained why they are now
expanding their pronouns to include she
her but if she's you so if she did then
we can say she and her apparent i don't
really understand at all that sentence
doesn't make sense if it
probably never did but now we can say
she and her so stop saying they if you
don't have to i mean look you love
bio has been updated to include all the
pro all their pronouns they them she her
what is so shocking about this gender
identity much like sexuality can be a
very fluid thing blah blah blah so i am
i've always i'm friends with blair white
like i
happy to call people by their preferred
pronouns
there has to be an upper bound on how
many times someone can
cause headlines and change them and then
there's a ton of outrage misleading
headlines this is still in the daily
beast article misleading headlines about
how lovato reverted back to she her
pronouns um because people said that
she'd stopped being they them and was
exclusively going to she her which isn't
correct uh the daily mail has got it
incorrect and basically people are being
this daily based article is shouting at
other
coverage
saying that you need to do better you
need to be able to understand there's
bigotry and there's social media chatter
and all this stuff and you go look
it's it's really hard and if someone's
going to continue to update their
pronouns like you have to actually even
says i understand that the world of
pronouns can be a little bit difficult
for people we just have to hope that
everybody's doing their best and yet
most of the people that are commenting
about this are using it as a political
football that they can kick around to
say you're a bigot because you don't
understand
what to me is another level of
complexity on top of the pronoun thing
so let's think about language for a
second pronouns themselves are to make
the language simpler
easier i don't have to say
chris every time i can say he i can say
him it's a placeholder and what you're
doing is making something that's simple
you're making it much more confusing
right so even just a minor amount of
confusion is kind of a big deal in the
english language because we don't know
how to speak then and
what's really weird is that the daily
beast says they
and then calls her she and then also
says that it's okay to call her she and
her
so what is like what's going on like
what what's the statement being made
so she wants to say that we can call her
she now great
but
i don't understand how that fits into to
what we were doing prior i i i'm not
into i mean it stays here i've actually
adopted the pronoun she her again she
told the host on this podcast so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
find that i am i felt like especially
last year my energy was balanced in my
masculine and feminine energy so when i
was faced with the choice of walking
into a bathroom and it said men women
and men i didn't feel like there was a
bathroom for me because i didn't
necessarily feel like a woman and i
didn't feel like a man i just felt like
a human recently i've been feeling more
feminine so i've adopted she her again
she said adding that the purpose of
using they them pronouns is about
feeling human at your core uh lovato
went on to assure others that nobody's
perfect and everybody messes up pronouns
at some point and especially when people
are learning it's all just about respect
so demi lovato seems completely fine
with people trying their best to keep up
with this stuff
there has to be an upper bound on how
many i mean if she decides to add in
more pronouns is this is there another
wave of headlines that should come up
out about it should people be lambasted
for not using it there's going to be
more pronouns that you can use than
can't use like it's i don't know it it's
a very interesting situation to get into
because i've never i don't think there's
been a real public situation where
somebody has added extra pronouns in now
and i i don't understand what the rules
are supposed to be around this
well i don't think there are rules but i
think that
again i would agree with you in that i
don't really care if somebody wants some
sort of preferred pronouns it's just
going to be very difficult for me to
unlearn
years of speaking to people
uh if if i misgender somebody like
honestly i will feel bad and i will try
to actually call them what they want but
it's it's much more difficult when you
mix in plurals
that's where for me
that sentence that you were trying to
read
that is
that's very frustrating right i don't
actually care that she she can name
herself whatever she wants
okay but the moment that we start mixing
in plurals and [ __ ] like that that's
where i start to be like hey this is uh
this is kind of [ __ ]
because then because then i can't
formulate a sentence properly without
being like i don't i don't know what to
do and that's that's ultimately what i'm
not a fan of originally i think this was
what um peterson was concerned about
whatever back in 2015 or 16 that it was
a way for people to
enact power over others
that you can force other people to
change their behavior based on a claim
that you make there's very few things
that i can force you to do right like
you could even walk into me if we were
going down a corridor on the same side
of the corridor i don't even i can't
even force you to move but by
using this that does give people the
opportunity to have a little bit of
power
but i don't know it seems like
it's just a very very strange situation
it's a very strange situation uh
speaking of strange situations beyonce
heated lyrics you mentioned this to me
and i've gone and had a look beyonce's
new album renaissance has been met with
overwhelmingly positive reviews but the
acclaimed singer faced backlash from
activists after friday's record-breaking
release for a lyric deemed ableist on
the song heat which britney co beyonce
co-wrote with drake she sings spazzing
on that ass spaz on that ass
that's the first time i've heard the
lyric i knew it was spazz
let me give you the full lyrics here
okay well it's about it's a for it's
it's about uh [ __ ] cerebral palsy
which is an actual term right it's a
and is that now a term that we're not
allowed to use well right as similar to
the same british thing i think so but
saying someone is [ __ ]
medically so is actually not allowed
even
now
right and i would is is the term [ __ ]
cerebral palsy or whatever however you
say it is that now
in that same boat that's just
first people would still be referred to
as um whatever [ __ ] and [ __ ]
that's like a medical diagnosis the
concern is when it becomes a pejorative
right and people start using it as a
slur i think the i don't even know that
they're allowed to medically say that
anymore
[ __ ] well they definitely are around
the [ __ ] thing because the person
that brought the term up is like
self-referred as that so okay presumably
it is at least a little bit so let me
let me give you some of the lyrics
bad bad [ __ ] make that bad [ __ ]
glitchy fine fine fine fine fine fine
fine fine liberated living like we ain't
got time yada yada ya yada yada yaya
yadda yadda yadda bombbom kaka
spazzin on that ass spazz on that ass
fan me girl
fan me quick girl i need my glass fan me
off my wrist goes click dimples on my
hips stretch marks on my tits drinking
my water minding my biz monday i'm
overrated tuesday on my dick
the worst thing about that apparently is
the spaz
yeah i have no idea i feel like i just
blacked out and i have no idea what you
just said
[Laughter]
i have no idea what just happened that
was really really weird you know how you
just kind of like space out while
someone's talking that's exactly what i
just did to you i apologize but it was
like
i was just hearing noises come out of
your mouth and in in no way did they
make sense at all
and suddenly we care about the word
[ __ ] you are not you are not beyonce
one of the greatest songwriters of a
generation so
oh yeah
but they've gone back and they've uh
she's retroactively changing the lyrics
she's going to change the lyrics so that
it says blast in instead of spazzing i
remember as well they already did it by
the way are they updated already yes but
there have been some vinyls that were
pressed already
[Music]
vinyls and cds that were pressed already
so
i imagine those would actually be the
resale on those
oh you got the spaz edition of beyonce's
new album bro
oh
yeah dude i'm i'm all for i mean i i've
always thought that that word was a bit
touchy because in the uk that's a word
that's been used quite a bit as a
pejorative and i remember watching iron
man and in it tony stark do you remember
when he's got social anxiety he's got
anxiety and he's having anxiety attacks
and he's with a little kid i think it's
in the third one and it's snowing and
the kids saying like um what's going on
where are we going can you help what's
happening are you okay you're breathing
fast and he's trying to calm himself
down and can't goes and sits over a far
side and says see you made me spaz out
he says that tony stark says that
coming out of hollywood and that was
only maybe
within 10 years ago yeah um so i always
that stuck in my mind that bit stuck in
my mind because i always thought [ __ ]
l
that's a bit of a heavy word to just be
thrown around like that so well look you
you know where this is going correct
that in people will bring issues about
certain things that have already been
made and demand that they change them
and what's wild is that we're doing it
to something that we thought we couldn't
change given that so
given that most people stream music now
we can actually take songs out and put
them back oh yeah yeah yeah and that's a
wild thing you can't even do that with
youtube videos right you could do that
with you'd have to re-upload the youtube
video yeah well i i think they probably
re-uploaded i don't know how how it
works yeah but it's just a very weird
thing but now this is where where the
conversation is ultimately going to go
is like the the potential for slippery
slope and obviously
so how far back do you need to go in
order to correct context yeah i mean are
we are we just gonna
there's gotta be
very very problematic content that so
many rappers
so many songs have used the word spat so
many things have like said i remember
eminem's eminem songs
50 cent songs with it in
yeah i mean it just it it's endless so
what are we gonna do we just gonna go
through and pick apart all these things
this is you know this is the the
slippery slope i mean and then we have
the the monica lewinsky thing what
happened with that so monica lewinsky
she said while we're at it
you can change the lyrics to this song
where you mention me like sucking
bill clinton's dick or something i don't
know actually if they'd had anything i
don't know what the lyric is i know that
i looked i looked at it earlier on so it
was uh like monica lewinsky done my
dress
so she was used
it was like someone's come on a dress
yeah okay so then so yeah but here's the
thing it's like monica lewinsky uh what
are you doing why do we care about you
type of thing that's kind of my re
reaction
monica lewinsky why do we care about you
at least i don't know is she big on
twitter or something she did a ted she
did a tedx talk or a ted talk a couple
of years ago that was pretty big
i guess she's just
been at the center of america well maybe
that was rude of me because like i
personally i'm i'm because i have no
idea what might it was
it was before our time i think that
whole situation and tracking the monica
lewinsky
did you see that
stranger things
went back and changed
something in season three because fans
pointed out the plot hole that's dude
this is gonna be endless
endless how many things have we seen
where they've gone back and taken
episodes out
i mean whole things whole seasons of
[ __ ] has been altered on hulu i can't
off the top of my head i can't think of
but there have been people who have had
scandals and then they've gone in and
taken their stuff off of streaming that
that for sure has happened for sure yeah
crystalia yeah he was uh taken out of a
movie completely and they re-shot his
scenes
um with obviously a much less funny
person but that's different to going
back and after it's been published in
his outreach retroactively so for me i
don't think that the plot hole thing is
not that big of a deal like if you've
missed something and the fans tell you
go back and fix it that scene oh oh oh
that's oh i didn't know that's why they
did this that for stranger things yeah
yeah it was there wasn't something
problematic i mean outrage no it was
people were outraged but they were
outraged because there was a hole in the
plot and they went back and fixed that
so that's that's one type i guess
another one is during the production or
before it's released you find out
something about somebody that's
contributed to it and they get removed
that's also an element i don't have any
problem with that either but when it
comes to getting rid of stuff from many
many years ago i can absolutely see
i could absolutely see that happening
and the difference being is it better to
alter i actually don't think it is
it's definitely not better to go back
and alter something than delete it
outright i think it's better to
completely remove content from the ins
like if you have to give me which
version of hell do you want the version
where stuff gets deleted
for all of altered yeah precisely
because that's not the original vision
for the piece of work but they're both
versions of hell correct correct correct
yeah it's like that uh that guy the meme
of that guy with his hand up and he's
got to pick one of the two buttons yes
yeah he's sweating yeah yeah so uh this
is something that i was just thinking
through
this whole outrage culture is is bad
because
it's becoming it might become less
viable to use outright outrage for good
i think that there's actually been a lot
in cinema that's happened where outrage
was good
so for instance the sonic the hedgehog
outrage what was that they released the
trailer for sonic the hedgehog and the
handy looked horrifying okay so what
they did was they fixed the way that he
looked went back in and changed him
completely and everyone was like thank
you this is a better movie now
straight up this is a straight up better
movie um there's a lot of there was a
lot of people saying okay hey we need a
deadpool movie and we need it to be
rated r it needs to be legit came out
one of the most successful superhero
movies at the time and so i think
that outrage that kind of feedback is
really awesome but what you're gonna see
is
people are gonna be like
well this is just outrage you know this
is just outrage culture [ __ ] them we're
not gonna listen to them because this is
what people do now
right so you get that kind of the boy
cried boy who cried wolf effect and i
think that's gonna suck a lot if it
hasn't already happened
it's a problem that people have around
overusing the accusation of racism right
if everything is racist then nothing's
racist and when you actually need to
call out some real racists
where do you go it's this ever uh
intensity increasing
situation and yeah you know if if
outrage occurs at
every corner every opportunity
then yeah when some real outrage is
needed you're going to be so
desensitized to it that you're not even
going to notice
yeah i mean and also how many people are
going to be like oh like
i guess
i guess i'm a [ __ ] racist if if
everyone's just going to call that and
then they're just going to
lean into it yeah they're gonna lean
into it that is what trolls do that is
what the alt-right is all about
right you tell me what i am fine i'll
[ __ ] be that and i'm gonna troll this
i'm gonna be the worst version of that
that you can imagine that's essentially
what like the the whole issue with the
alt-right is right you it's almost like
the left creates it the okay symbol is a
great example of this
okay the okay symbol is uh what was it
like
white power looks like a w and a p yeah
that was something that was created on
the backboards of 4chan
brought up and then they're like look we
[ __ ] got this these guys and then the
actual you know
white nationalist parties were like [ __ ]
it we'll use it sure if it pisses off
the left we'll [ __ ] use it yeah and
we don't know what's real we don't know
what a joke is you know poe's law have
you heard of poe's law it's it's
basically states that there is
absolutely no way of knowing that
something is satirical on the internet
unless it is stated
because what you can get into this
endless feedback loop of people
saying it was satirical but then taking
the satire and making it real and making
it a part of it and kind of creating
this weird
cycle and and poe's law is a is a
product of the internet and i think that
this is sort of the stuff that we'll end
up running into more and more how many
things have been created off of 4chan
that have become something did you see
that did you see that free bleeding did
you ever see this no okay so
people on 4chan wanted
to try and troll women
into believing that showing period blood
on your clothes
was
a way of standing in solidarity with
people that don't have access to birth
control maybe or people in the middle
east so they created this campaign and
many many many women started doing what
was called free bleeding
and just allowing period blood to go on
the outside of their clothes because
that was in solidarity with their
sisters in
asia or whatever it was
i mean the the biggest one we can think
of is the board ape yacht club right
that is
something that was directly
created as kind of a joke
and it ended up being a billion dollar
troll yeah and for people who don't know
people that don't know what we're
talking about once you finish this
episode go over to fillion's channel on
youtube and watch boarded nazi club even
if you don't think that it's true it's
one of the best heart like hours of
independent filmmaking it's so so
thorough and it's fascinating all of the
different imagery basically he's saying
that board api club is a a larpy sort of
troll
of
alt-right
imagery references stuff to do with hylo
hitler stuff to do with the jews stuff
to do with auschwitz all sorts of stuff
and he just lays it out over and out so
you should go and check that out once
we're finished and i think this is also
something interesting especially with
the board ape yacht club
are they actually are they actually
racist even though they're putting
racist things in there
to get something out of it but then they
themselves might not be or they might be
but it's all about the troll yeah
right the real life troll and what we
need to distinguish is
does trolling mobilize actual racism
which
might be true or is it just trolling for
trolling's sake like this how are you
supposed to deal with it as well like
are you are you suggesting or would it
be the case that you should let
troll racism go
in order to not go but that's the thing
we cannot again this goes back to poe's
law we cannot discern what a troll is
and what isn't you could point to
something and say it's satirical but the
creator of it could be like no this
wasn't satire
he could say whatever he or she could
say whatever the [ __ ] they want
it's super interesting very very
comfortable and it's it's it's very
important to understand this because
like meme culture and meta culture and
and and this 4chan it it is where we are
headed if we're not there already
whoever can create the the
most clever
timely maybe contrarian opinion in a
funny way that is relatable wins
and by the time it's either proved
incorrect
or or correct it's already too late
because it's viralized
so many people like just love the way
that that meme is formatted because it
speaks to them it doesn't matter but now
their opinion is not is like
yeah [ __ ] yeah you you gave me my
opinion on a platter it's the biases
that people have and this is just how it
works like the power of memes
is limitless
and there's uh there's also like a meme
economy i don't know if you know much
about this i don't really know too much
about it but essentially it's like stock
in memes you can see which meme is going
to outperform right like there's i
think there is a list of current memes
and like where they are ranked and and
certain things like that and think about
that for a second if you want to say
something that makes a difference you
find a powerful meme
and you can throw that out into the
world oh i'll tell you where i've gone
so i've just typed in meme economy
online and you know the website that's
come up to explain it to me know your
meme.com no you're meme yes yeah so was
he was a guy on your show correct no we
met him we met him i met him at uh
malice's party a few weeks ago the guy
oh yeah okay yeah he was fascinating i
met with sky and uh so how much of that
could then relate to crypto which also
could then relate to the stock market
it's [ __ ] crazy to think about this
were we always as a culture were we
always
doomed or headed to something like this
where everything is meta everything is
well think about think about it this way
we're talking about movies and stuff
like that how long has it been since
there was a normal
superhero movie that didn't have to have
some weird quirk
on the side of the character you know
that i mean we've got
hero movies now that are based on the
villains that's what suicide squad was
right like right
you have movies like the boys on amazon
prime which everybody should go and
watch because it's amazing it's amazing
it's amazing and all of those characters
it that's super super sort of
fourth degree remove fifth degree
removed meta commentary about so it's
interesting i wonder whether part of it
is
because once you've played out
very easy to guess archetypes and roles
you know if we just did another the
first superman right from whatever the
50s or something if we just put that out
again
we've already done that we've already
you know that's been done to death so i
do think that it's kind of an inevitable
progression of the art form but when it
leaks over into news into normal culture
outside of the creative world and the
creative world and the cultural world
and news and politics have all become
intertwined because everybody's a pocket
creator now right yes your dog does
something funny you take a photo of it
that could be the most famous dog ever
remember the guy that did that
lightsaber thing what's that 20 years
ago now probably on the internet the
lightsaber dude
chocolate rain you remember him yes yes
all of this stuff man like you get
turned into memes the uh fish and rice
cakes dude from england
he got invited so here's a funny one the
guy that did fish and rice cakes got
invited onto first dates which is a
dating program in the uk it's one of the
biggest ones he got invited on there and
he looks great he's got like half sleeve
tattoo pretty cool good looking guy and
he was explaining about how he was
um like misrepresented on there and then
i think he also did a video on lad bible
explaining it as well it's not nice i
mean sony gave those four lads in jeans
uh that were british as well he they
gave them a contract for
noise-cancelling headphones because of
like keeping the haters out so this is
meme culture then getting fed back into
advertising and yep
back into the cultural machine yeah yeah
everything's clickbait man speaking of
movies and stuff like that batgirl and
scooby-doo holiday haunts scrapped at
warner brothers amid cost savings push
so batgirl budgeted at around 80 million
dollars with costs rising up to nearly
90 million due to covid in a surprising
development warner brothers will no
longer be releasing batgirl the dc film
that had already completed shooting and
was expected to arrive on hbo max this
year the unusual move comes after a
change in leadership at one is with
newly installed warner brothers
discovery ceo david zaslav prioritizing
cost cutting matches and uh refocusing
warner's on creating theatrical films
rather than just projects for streaming
as had been a priority for former warner
media ceo jason killer batgirl was
budgeted at around 80 million dollars
with costs rising to nearly 90 million
due to covet 19 protocols it's a hefty
sum but significantly lower than dc
theatrical releases thus the film is
said to not have the spectacle the
audience have come to expect from dc
fair the batman released in march had a
budget of 185 million before marketing
costs one has also decided to shelve
animated feature scoob holiday haunt
which had a budget in the 40 million
range so
i am not a massive fan of the
current trend that we're seeing of
trying to rinse every single franchise
and squeeze it as hard as possible you
know we had she-hulk not long ago that
came out in the cinema and it was
it didn't even make sense in
the
hulk universe because the hulk wasn't
able to speak
when he was hulk he was enraged she's
able to go to work she's like a
high-powered boss [ __ ] lawyer with a
briefcase there's a scene where she
picks some guy up that she's having a
one-night stand with picks him up from
the couch and walks him into bed it's
like a total reversal like gender role
reversal thing
but it sucked let me see what she
hulk
rotten tomatoes what did it get
she hulk attorney at law that's
literally
literally what it's called
uh
is it out
tv series it might not be out i think oh
release date 2022 yeah well i've seen a
lot of oh premiere's on august 18th so
it'll be out pretty soon
so something tells me it's going to have
a brutal rotten tomatoes score outside
of the content sucking right what makes
me the most angry is the ridiculous
waste of money
okay as somebody who is currently trying
to make a feature film happen
who's trying to raise money and really
passionate about a certain project
to see someone go through an entire w is
it a single film or is it a c series
okay series for eight sorry 90 million
dollars shoot it all and then never put
it out
that is so unbelievably frustrating but
it points to
the fact that
the best culture cannot possibly be
created by the top
not always like the best music for this
this person or the best
uh cinema for this person will likely
not be created at the top for that
person at least not to the degree that
we think it is
okay
if if production is just a money throw
like throw money at it pump it out send
it out
and we have the biggest market we have
the best streaming service
eat it up people
right that that happens ad nauseum and
like to kind of circle back to the
beyonce thing
right the the
another part to this was that she took a
sample from kalis
and uh
milkshake yes
actually kind of a good song kind of a
banger yeah but
before any of that happened before she
didn't give credit at all
the neptunes which is pharrell
they owned the song and basically
tricked her out of not getting any money
on but i think both of her first two
albums which they both produced she
signed a contract and she really did not
make the money that she should have made
and what happened was beyonce then used
milkshake which then brought
that back into the fray she used
milkshake without the vocal though right
she just raised the sample of the
instrument which was owned by pharrell
which who was also helping to produce
beyonce's album exactly which all it
pointed to was that this [ __ ]
weird world of production of creativity
still exists and it still [ __ ] sucks
it's still
absolutely level yes and we live in a
world now where you and i can go on the
internet and create our content without
any oversight at all and i i do believe
that the fact that that's happening is
awesome to put more and more stress on
the people up top who [ __ ] over the real
creators in this world or the very
talented people in this world
i i honestly i honestly believe that
yeah man i mean
there's another element here i think of
um
cherished and treasured franchises and
series
being ruined what's that quote about you
either die the hero or live long enough
to see yourself become the villain yes
that's what's happening with media now
every company every franchise is just
rinsing you know what the most
impressive thing i think is the avengers
finished
the avengers stopped that has to be the
most successful
uh movie franchise of the last maybe
ever but certainly of the last few years
maybe since harry potter something like
that it'll be it'll be definitely up
there and they just went
spoiler alert for people that haven't
seen it we're going to kill the main
character at the end and then it's going
to finish and obviously they've got you
know
loki series they've got all sorts of
split-offs so maybe marvel isn't an
amazing example because they're still
rinsing the universe outside of it but
they stopped that bit and that felt like
do you not think that it's sad but it's
kind of satisfying and it almost makes
that series or
what would you call it that sequence of
movies feel more special because you
know i love it as a full stop yes no i
love it i think um ozark did a great job
of that i haven't seen they're like hard
stop it's over we're done they you know
they built the [ __ ] story i think
from day one they had the same story it
wasn't they were building as they were
going they weren't trying to see where
near the end already they knew the end
and i think you know if you look at
my
debatably one of my favorite shows ever
created
was true detective season one never seen
okay so that's matthew mcconaughey woody
harrelson a couple other people
but a fantastic story and not only that
like very very good cinematography and
direction
uh and at the time i i mean i still
think it's for me top five maybe top
three maybe the best one that i can
think of off the top of my head
they ended that series matthew
mcconaughey and woody harrelson were
done so now they have to start they do
true detective but they start a
completely new
uh
place on a new idea a new story arc news
investigators
yes and it has nothing to do with that
first one i think that's okay
but in my opinion that was their way of
being like look we can be
legit we can end this story but we can
keep this series alive and hopefully
milk people for more money when they
should have literally just been like
that's it we're done one season we're
out okay so i'll push back against that
think about if they'd come in with the
second season and the second season was
better than the first season
if they'd been able to do that
i think that you would have gone and you
know what they did they came back it was
really good it was different it was my
point being that a lot of what we're
saying here we're trying to rationalize
like a hard and fast rule about don't
make female versions of [ __ ] existing
superheroes if it's good it's good
precisely yeah we what we really mean is
don't ruin [ __ ]
don't make
terrible movies and series the same
thing goes for game of thrones i oh yeah
i've just spouted on for ages about how
we shouldn't be rinsing the [ __ ] out of
franchises and making terrible things
and house of dragons and beyond the wall
or whatever the one that's about the
north is uh both of those are coming out
pretty soon and i can't wait i'm
absolutely gasps for those to come out i
think that game of thrones was
particularly unsatisfying the way that
it finished and i also think that this
will probably be pretty cool and i like
george rr martin's universe so i want
that so i like it it's difficult to
please i like they were that they were
rinsed solely because
they were trying to get out of there
those two guys benehoff and whatever don
and dave
they were trying to get the [ __ ] out of
there
they were like we're done with this
we're gonna go make a star wars movie
we're going over to luca's pictures
that's why i that's why i think [ __ ]
them rinse them destroy them
um not only did they make a piece of
[ __ ] ending to an amazing series that
was actually pretty accurate to the
books and even though they were allowed
to finish how they kind of wanted to
because the books hadn't been out yet
they they were like let's get out of
here and that's how it felt maybe that's
not how it was but you could even see um
did you see the cast
table the video of them at the casting
table where they like look at the [ __ ]
and they're like yes
what yeah you know like people were
watching this and they were like this is
not who i am this is not how i am
another another one of that is um the
guy who plays luke skywalker throughout
the whole series i can't think of his
name it's pathetic of me i'm sorry oh
hamel something hamill i think whatever
uh
he
he was like in interviews
i think he might have been a little
boozed up or something but he's like
this [ __ ] sucks you know or like
not
not that not that but it was
like he virtually had said like this is
not have you seen good what we just made
was not good so there's a
a bunch of interviews that people can go
and watch with the cast of game of
thrones
after they'd finished filming season
eight but before it had been aired and
in all of the interviews when they're
being asked so tell us you know is it
exciting or is it whatever kit
harrington's the best because he's
british and pretty much unable to
keep his
like emotions to himself it's just so
obvious they're dying inside they don't
they like they're just completely
unsatisfied with it another person
that's amazing when it comes to media
interviews have you seen tom holland the
guy that does spider-man yes he's seen
how much he [ __ ] up yeah and how much
he gives away like what ends up
happening yeah people people don't let
him [ __ ] speak anymore they said
about um was it avengers whatever the
one where thanos snaps his fingers and
during the press tour for that it was
something like uh
um
with
the interviewer said we're scared of
losing more people or something
something something and tom holland
literally responded and said well
half of everybody dies in this episode
or like
okay okay this is a crazy one ready for
this
so a star is born i'm going in to see it
with my buddy i'm actually really stoked
for this movie uh and
it's one of those
movie theaters where you get food served
to you
and so we go to sit down and our
waitress comes out
and she's like
she's like hey look the ending is really
sad so i'm actually gonna um try and get
you guys to pay before about 20 minutes
before it ends
and we're i literally look at her i'm
like
okay so uh bradley cooper dies this is
what you're telling me right i didn't
say that i didn't say that to her but my
jaw dropped she walks away and i just
immediately knew it i knew what happened
all you had to say was it's sad you just
had to say that how about just don't
[ __ ] say that and now i was thinking
about it how many people's movie it
going experience did this one lady ruin
thinking that she was getting on top of
her job
you know what i mean like
not only not only on that day but over
the course of the month yes she ruined
that [ __ ] so my housemate my housemate
back in the uk toby
has this unbelievable ability to see
what's going to happen in series so if
it's a murder mystery within
half an hour he's like he did it and
sure enough it's him so
i imagine that if you're really smart at
being able to detect narratives i'm
completely not so i'm always surprised
at the end and oblivious to whatever's
going on
i imagine it's kind of the same if
you're one of those people that's really
talented at being able to pick out who
did the thing and looking for nuance and
she went to the left or whatever
this is basically the same thing because
you there's no surprise at the end of it
i don't know whether you know about a
youtube channel called emergency awesome
he does he does analysis and breakdowns
of trailers and series and one of the
best things that happened during game of
thrones was i'd watch the episode and
then i'd go and watch his half hour long
breakdown that explained all of this
stuff and i knew that
uh jon snow was a targaryen oh yeah yeah
actually i watched a ton of that and
also yeah i i was just really into a
wiki of ice and fire i don't know if you
know what that is it's basically the the
wikipedia for that series so when i was
bored i was just because i was
man i was really really obsessed with
not just game of thrones but uh um a
song of ice and fire like i was really
really into it so
very early on mind you i was a sophomore
in college when it started coming out so
it's like
my consumption of this was cons
considerable i mean it was literally 10
years of my life or over that where i
was like into this thing and to have it
end like it did was that was the slap in
the face but sorry i interrupted you no
that was it man just that i i imagine
that if you've got an unbelievable
insight when it comes to movies
i wouldn't say i have an unbelievable
insight but with a star is born i knew
because like the trailer had kind of
alluded to bradley cooper being a piece
of [ __ ] right or or hav or being this
this uh doomed rock star
okay and the moment the woman comes up
to me and says hey it's a sad ending
so i want to get out of here
like i don't want to like interrupt the
ending or something like that and i'm
just like oh so he dies
thanks he dies okay cool let's get on
with the movie thank you
look dude immediately yeah let's bring
this one home uh your current movie
project that you're looking for funding
for where can people go to check that
out uh go to wefunder.com and then
search the weight so it's the weight llc
we created an llc we created a lot of
stuff to get this weight w-e-i-g-h-t
yes the weight and uh right now we have
over 150 000
raised and we have
uh a lead investor
we have a lot of things in place um the
back end is completely full like we have
everything we need to get this thing
going um and people can not just donate
they can invest and actually have the
potential to make their money back and
make more money but also be
part of the production of the first
weightlifting based narrative feature
film and your socials and all that stuff
as well where should people go yeah uh
coach underscore zt on instagram and my
name's zach tellinger on youtube all
right dude appreciate you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace